vert rouge vert rouge 7
les lignes défensives peaufine les
combinaisons les Templiers sont dans la
phase terminale de leur préparation
avant la reprise du championnat de
France élite à l'intersaison le groupe a
très peu changé le staff a pu rentrer
plus vite dans le vif du sujet on en
restait dans la continuité donc
on a pu tourner
tourner plus de jeux que ce qu'on
faisait par le passé il y a moins
d'installations et on rentre plus dans
les phases de d'opposition et de
d'ajustement l'équipe 56 vient de
boucler son recrutement avec la venue de
Viny Roth le quarterback américain est
le meilleur joueur européen en 2010
rejoindra le groupe début janvier après
avoir fait l'ascenseur la saison
dernière en division 2 les joueurs
d'Emmanuel Charest retrouve l’élite mais
pour l'instant sans trop de repères on
commence directement par les champions
de France en titre
donc ça va nous permettre tout de suite
de voir où on en est si on les accroche
si on gagne si on perd largement voilà
on pourra après définir les objectifs
France après un ou deux matchs
puisque c'est des équipes qu'on n'a pas
rencontré depuis deux ans mais bon je
suis plutôt plutôt confiant j'espère
qu'on va faire une bonne saison qu'on
essayait de faire une petite surprise
d'aller en playoff et pourquoi pas plus
les Templiers ont reporté leurs deux
premiers matchs amicaux face à des
équipes de division inférieures de quoi
monter en intensité et s'assurer un
capital confiance jusqu'au lancement du
championnat mi-février